let the momentum of the car do the work
for you it's all in the wrist not bad
now you want to see a thing of beauty
bingo bango Bungo that's good it's good
to be positive despite making zero
progress in a year you thought that they
disappeared forever but this is the
moment we've all been waiting for
gentlemen the four horsemen and the girl
horsemen yeah nope
are you listening horseman you will get
what's coming to you thank you
everything ways you can't expect hey
it's great to be bad
now the greatest magicians in the world
or my magic trick everyone get off the
stage we jump off a rooftop in New York
where the hello landed in China how is
this possible
so simply my move next one is yours
somebody got the better of us okay
somehow yes you were lured into a trap
Dada this is the key to every computer
system on the planet I want you to steal
it for me people are still gonna play a
little game I know you will we're going
out with the show
people will never forget
hey do that myself thanks for having us
not long ago we were tricked let's go
let's go so really fitting that we do
the same thing to the person who did it
to us damn it feels good to be back
hello hello
make it go up
as always Horton was on the surface
you